they come in the night
firing stun grenades and live rounds
soldiers and police roaming residential
neighborhoods
shooting into buildings smashing
property as they pass
for some these are detention squads
seizing protest leaders
politicians and civil servants dragged
away
to an uncertain fate elsewhere they're
cleaning up
peeling stickers of the coup leader
general minong lai
off the road but for those watching from
behind twitching curtains
it's clear they have one main goal to
intimidate
the yangon resident who filmed this told
al jazeera that 40 armed soldiers and
police
had been searching houses for members of
the national league for democracy
or nld
the whole of our neighborhood in jokta
is frightened we can't sleep at night in
case they come back but the protesters
have some mind games to play too
in many areas clotheslines of women's
skirts or long g's as they're known
and underwear are now hanging overhead
playing on the superstitions of the
soldiers
and police
the reason why we hang the languages
across the street is that we have the
traditional belief that if we pass
underneath olanji
we might lose our luck the younger
generation nowadays doesn't believe it
anymore but the soldiers still do
and it's their weakness so we might gain
more time to run if they come towards us
against the security services these
obstacles are more effective
than barricades or barbed wire
and as the sun sets another sad ritual
in modern myanmar
vigils for those who've died on the
streets in the cities of yangon mandalay
darwin and elsewhere
the candles burn to commemorate a
growing list of names
until the darkness and the security
services claim the streets
once more tony chang al jazeera